hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einer neuen
episode fortnight ich habe den besten
aller zeiten
ich bin allerdings heute keine normale
runde fordert battle royale wo wir uns
mit anderen leuten um den epischen sieg
schlagen denen ich bei beiden noch nie
gewonnen habe
wir befinden uns nämlich heute hier
wieder in einer custom map und zwar
haben wir vorne stand eine falle und
muss das so dass man dadurch fällt
ich glaube ich habe die map zerstört
laser luca hat aufgegeben die märkte wie
heute spielen ist ein test ran und zwar
ist es ein
der 3.0 dettmann von es geht hierbei auf
jeden fall darum dass man so schnell wie
möglich diesen deadline hier besteht und
durch diese als trick es ist so ähnlich
wie diese drop map die wir letztens
schon mal gespielt haben nur dass wir
nicht irgendwo runterfallen müssen
sondern dass wir uns den weg durch
bahnen müssen wir bisher relativ gut
hingekriegt und jetzt ist das jetzt das
werk ist es jetzt gut oder schlecht ich
weiß nicht was wir hier machen müssen
ich kann ja schlecht da drüber laufen
sind ja fallen wenn ich da das geht
nicht so läuft das heutige video auf
jeden fall ab wir müssen uns also hier
den weg in sehr gut luca wir müssen uns
hier den weg durch pannen und dürfen uns
dabei nicht aufhalten lassen von
irgendwelchen fallen von irgendetwas
anderem kommen die jetzt jedoch durch
hallo bisschen geschafft
doch nicht geschafft das wichtigste
allerdings erstmal hier direkt zu beginn
des videos freunde create luca ich würde
mich sehr freuen wenn ihr als support
creator konnte luca eingeben würde bei
fortnight dadurch kann ich ein bisschen
geld verdienen und ihr zeit nichts mehr
also es ist wind für euch und für mich
und für alle beteiligten allerdings
werde ich jetzt erst mal schnell das
level hier bestehen damit ich mach das
level war schnell fertig damit ihr seht
hey support player kommt luca lohnt sich
wirklich den einzugeben das ist so ein
brachial guter spieler
ich sehe es ja schon wieder verpackt
scheiße das kann doch nicht so schwer
sein also wir müssen auf jeden fall
erstmal hier an der seite her hier
schnell rüber springen hier schnell
drüber hier und jetzt weiß ich halt
nicht wie hier
da kann ich immer gegen dieses teil
gegen craig ich wollte auch den besten
spieler aller zeiten finanziell
unterstützen oder spieltag ich weiß
nicht wie ich das machen soll
ich habe halt noch diese zeit trifft
hier drin das heißt ich muss eigentlich
hier so ich habe immer gegen diesen
posten
hierüber hier an der seite um das war
sehr sehr sehr gut und jetzt hier zeigt
ok sehr gut sehr gut und jetzt hier
durch luca stark geschafft muss nein
nein muss man ist ja das schaffe ich
schon dieses kacke level hier und kommen
hinten auf diese plattform aber jetzt
weiß ich eigentlich wie es geht also
hierüber und jetzt muss ich hier hinten
durchlaufen und jetzt hier hoch zack
hoch springen auf der anderen seite
wieder rüber hier überspringen hierhin
cent sagt ich hab's oder ding ja und das
war erst das erste level es gibt halt so
richtige runs sehr gut es gibt so eine
richtige competition auf youtube wo dann
leute ihre habe ich die gefakte alter
doch nicht es gibt so richtige
competitions auf youtube wie soll ich da
drauf daher bin ich unsterblich
doch nicht luca hat sich ins eigene knie
geschossen
es gibt auf youtube auf jeden fall so
richtige computer wie soll ich denn da
drauf kommen es gibt so richtige zeiten
mit denen sich dann die leute irgendwie
messen die diese was hat für eine
scheiße
malta ist doch so klusmann das kann doch
nicht so schwer sein dass ich einfach
hier auf das ding drauf alle her was ist
und warum sterbe ich dann auch nicht
direkt hat sie mich mal töten hier hallo
danke es gibt auf youtube auf jeden fall
so richtige leute die sich dann so
betteln von wegen hey wer schafft die
bessere zeit schafft es einer unter
sechs minuten diesen ganzen landschaft
seiner unter sechseinhalb unter
fünfeinhalb keine ahnung und allerdings
bei mir ist erst mal das ding das ich
zeit überhaupt schaffen muss ich meine
es ist doch nicht so schwierig hier hoch
zuspruch ich bin so blöd ich werde nicht
mal getötet ich habe jetzt allerdings
eine idee wie ich das ganze mache und
zwar spiele ich hier so ein bisschen
seitlich und bam den tod näher aber das
ganze video hier ist ja mal ein toller
anlass dass ich mit euch mein gott wie
ich kann mich so ein bisschen reden über
fort hallo danke ich kann mit euch jetzt
so ein bisschen über streaming reden und
zwar hatte ich davor demnächst mal so
richtig anzufangen kommen junge ist doch
nicht so schwer oder dabei gesagt ich
halte euch auf dem laufenden
wir sind in verhandlungen mit switch bzw
sind fertig glaube ich sogar also ich
meine ich glaube ich habe jetzt ein
vertrag den fall habe ich da jetzt ganz
ganz viele neue funktionen und es wird
ganz ganz ganz ganz cool und ich wollte
euch nur sagen dass ich demnächst
loslegen werde allerdings nicht nur mit
ford livestream sondern tatsächlich
primär reaction streams wie ich auf
sachen reagiere weil ich will halt nicht
auf meinem youtube-kanal jeden tag in
action video hochladen da gibt's der
kanäle die montana black oder simon und
wirklich jeden tag nur videos hochladen
wo sie auf anderen content drauf
reagieren das möchte ich nicht möchte
noch weiterhin so sachen machen wie
jetzt beispielsweise hier ein bisschen
einspielen ich mache eure hausaufgaben
hab ich ja letztens gemacht oder
challenges et cetera allerdings gibt es
so viele videos auf youtube und auch so
viele hilfe videos etc auf die ich noch
gar nicht alle reagiert habe wo ich mir
wirklich denke ich möchte da gern darauf
reagieren und ich möchte mir die gerne
zusammen mit euch anschauen
bestimmt sind eigentlich perfekt gemacht
für reactions finde ich weil ihr können
wir in
livechat schreiben hey luca hast du
schon das video gesehen da ist was neues
vorgefallen der youtuber dies gemacht
oder hey guck mal eine neue folge mit
doppelter kann ich mir die halt im live
stream zusammen mit euch anschauen
ok nice nice nice okay wir haben einen
checkpoint ich kann mir dann auf jeden
fall im live stream zusammen mit euch
die videos anschauen und wurde gerade
von fünf seitens möbelt auf jeden fall
ist es glaube ich eine ganz gute idee
wenn der haupt sind meiner livestreams
darin besteht dass ich mit euch quasi
lada und eure fragen beantwortet und
auch sachen reagiere weil sowas wie vor
neid
da muss ich mich dann halt 20 minuten
lang auf einen match konzentrieren und
alter das ist hier nicht hinkriegen ich
glaube dass suri action und lover fragen
beantworten challenge live streams bei
mir am meisten treibt mir bitte gern mal
eure meinung dazu in die kommentare also
ich wollte demnächst auf jeden fall
auftritt durchstarten ich finde ja
meinen twitter link unten in der video
beschreibung immer eingeblendet ich bin
aufgesprungen also checkt auf jeden fall
gern mal die info box ab und schaut bei
ich hab's stark was sind das denn der
impuls
nein nein ich wie solchen da hochkommen
jetzt ging ja voll schnell jetzt haben
wir hier wieder sonne impuls granate und
nein oder ja also ich weiß noch nicht so
ganz was hier abgeht aber er schaut auf
jeden fall mal in der infobox vorbei da
ist ein okay da darf ich nicht hin in
der infobox ist ein link zu meinem
switch und da könnt ihr vorbeischauen es
dauert zwar noch ein paar wochen bis es
losgeht weil wir noch designs machen
wollte ich will das so geile smileys
haben mit pizza alpaka und sonst miley
und den ok typ und den strauß robert
benton artikel 13 kommt darfst deine
fresse nicht mehr benutzten du kleiner
falls passt einfach deine fresse auf
jeden fall könnte dagegen schon mal
vorbeischauen da geht es bald los aber
es werden wirklich hauptsächlich bin ich
gerade erst mal gestorben mein heutiges
ziel ist es auf jeden fall noch dieses
ding da oben zu kriegen
ich muss da drauf springen das heißt ich
bin tot
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo hallo wo kommst du her hallo hallo
wo kommst du her helfen halt die fresse
ich nehme gerade auf ich will ihr helfen
wo kommst du denn plötzlich leer aus
mexiko
das erklärt natürlich einiges bekommt
man dann durch diese dinger am anfang
durch ich ja springen ich bin schon ein
bisschen weiter ich bin ein profi ich
berühre das nicht mal nicht sterbe
trotzdem was muss man machen egal wie
bist du überhaupt hier hingekommen ich
nehme doch eigentlich so was auf ihren
ich hab's geschafft
ich habe es geschafft beim einem level
gerade ich sehe den fall zumindest hier
laufen jetzt wirst du thot viel spaß
hier noch und alles gute
dank hätte ja auch alles gute hieß ich
wünsche ihr viel spaß und liebe danke
auf jeden fall wie den jumper ja
schonmal hingekriegt wir müssen jetzt
auf jeden fall noch 4 hinten
oh mein gott walther ich bin kraft nötig
das ist doch nicht das muss ich noch da
hinten am 1
nein ist nicht wahr ich gehe da nicht
noch mal hin willst du mich verarschen
leiter anders stelle sich das heutige
video als auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat wie
ich mich ja bei diesem test ran hier
geschlagen habe das gerne einen daumen
hoch da schreibt beginnen und in die
kommentare wie sehr ihr revier hast
dafür dass er meine aufnahme gecrasht
hat ich würde mich sehr freuen wenn ihr
den create luca benutzen würde die müsst
ihr einfach hier eingeben und dann habt
ihr den quasi benutzt wenn ihr euch dann
im ford im shop irgendwie was kauft
neuen skin oder keine ahnung was dann
seid ihr genau den gleichen preis wie
vorher auch allerdings bekomme ich etwas
ab von dem geld was und epic games geht
wieder gute idee und ich bin jetzt das
video
[Musik]